today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza for all of your pizza
needs if you need it they got it if
you're in Los Angeles you could stop
over there get that taste get that vibe
get your mouth full
18:11 Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles on
the way to the beach gray block get that
hit or baby
today's guest is one of the most
successful and one of the most musically
maybe provocative or I don't know unique
men that there is in the music market he
has a new album out which is a kind of a
country well I don't know what to
classify we'll get into it a little bit
but it is Diplo presents Thomas Wesley
chapter one snake-oil is the new album I
suggest you check it out it's got some
real bangers on it
today's guest is none other than Diplo
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean you did it we didn't even want
riffraff here right was it here okay so
like he helped kind of yeah I mean I was
I remember he was living in Baltimore
and I just was watching videos and I had
a label
I saw the label called Madison now just
like man this guy something special
about him and I linked him and had him
come up to LA and we worked a little bit
and we made his I signed him to his
first album on my label which for me in
retrospect I think it was one of the
most groundbreaking hip-hop albums it's
like new generation and people don't
believe me but every time I work with a
young rapper they always brought him up
like cuz they're like 14 15 they watch
him on YouTube and he's like doing lines
of coke or like acting crazy or just
being unabashedly himself right yeah
yeah everybody is they had this free
Lycia and they see like this idea of
like the freedom that he did because he
was like and he was like the people on
worldstar would comment just he would
blow up on Wall Street was like [ __ ]
this like you know you're like what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] but it's like
drove the the videos up to were like so
confused and if you're like an older
person like I don't get that hip hop but
if you're like 14 15 like oh I love this
lovely honey aspect of this so like
that's a good word he's like punk hip
hop yeah he was Punk and he was just
everything was freestyle - I mean he was
so same with him I bet the podcast is
just so good cuz the guy's so fast like
he just oh he's a theory can everything
see freakin comes up with pools out of
space is just like what the [ __ ] bro
Iranian Lamborghini dude he has uh what
was the alcohol I want to give him I
know he has a new album out right now
going oh yeah vanilla gorilla so
everybody go and get that and support
riffraff man yeah I love him dude when I
so I went to his place in the water
field and yeah up in Deerfield so we get
there we go to the front door right and
I'm kind of nervous because it's almost
like meeting like an endangered species
yeah you don't know for the first time
you must be pretty daunting and creature
remember in Jurassic Park when they kind
of hurt milling around and they know
that their sores out there I made to see
the big old brontosaurus and it's kind
of like that yeah he's like that when
you're riding along you don't know where
the animals gonna kill ya
and then we get to the front door and it
has been welded shut
there is no way actual door yes it's
just a huge piece of metal
why do you get in row that's fine so I
start just saying things that I'd seen
on Harry Potter you know like still
trying to open the try open the door and
then he takes us it that he comes out
his ass isn't coming out through the
garage and he met us in there insistent
he had no if it's got Maserati Micah oh
yeah always has people around they're
just like crazy people I don't know
crazy but also slash Barber and Maserati
might give me some stripes in my head
too they were really really dope and I
felt like when he did that that I was
did he have the mullet when you
interview yeah he just got in it he has
a good mother
yeah oh he's got beautiful hair I cut
his brothers hair Victor is that he
don't know it's a grand Instagram mmm
and he has good yeah he has a good uh
yeah yeah
that's a young mo now your mullet slow
fuller punk you shade the insides a
little bit more yeah it's getting a
little more I have I had the straightest
hair that like my mullet I'm gonna get
him out soon because my last thing
before I just shave the head off because
are you going all the way back to that
brought 41 I mean like this is my last
chance to grow my hair long I don't
think this is like it was like an
accident I started doing it I'm just
like I can't turn back now it's like a
one-way street and I'm so scared I'd do
it I just give up on the dream of having
long hair Yeah right someone go to mow
it and I but have to straight ass hair
so it's gonna look like oh yeah it's
gonna yeah like a Joe Dirt like but I
don't I don't even I don't even have the
hair that sticks up there like how those
guys like the 80s guys had the [ __ ]
things that pop up it's nothing like
that's gonna look like I mean people of
any like I don't know if you can pull up
any Mullis eye or straight hair mullet
it's pretty yeah let's go straight yeah
I think his hair was bleached you so
much you got like fluffy but it's kind
of hard to do the straight hair mullet
man or straight it almost ring I didn't
want to say you said stream here I've
been here I'll be honest man it's like
and someone my last leg over here and
these are like these are like a lot of
women coming everyone that good a second
one that's what it's gonna look like a
prison I like that's what I'm gonna look
like bro and I think it's it's blond so
you're gonna think I'm bald really it's
gonna be pretty dude if you go full with
the front really really low-cut that's
gonna be a brave move but you're gonna
feel like a stallion yeah I mean who's
good Matt mullet is a diet
we're had good had a good mother died
from ninja die Antwoord he has a good
mother who totally uh he's a south
african rapper mmm and his girlfriend he
was always talking about him yeah oh
yeah oh wow he does his girl has a
really good mullet - oh yeah I'd watch
their heads you never see never seen
them uh-huh they're they're a rappers
from South Africa that like he's an
old-school hip-hop rapper yeah like from
that era from South Africa but he like
thinks Afrikaans like the wackest
culture in the world so he kind of like
made a fake version of Afrikaans rapper
as I kind of a joke but it was amazing
like this culture of like these kind of
like Cape Town like yeah been there a
couple times yeah they made fun of the
whole culture of like being like white
South African Afrikaans rapping and I
just made it actually cool he made his
amazing videos like super cutting-edge I
produce some of the music for them and
they made a movie about robots inside
that way they actually did amazing
things like fool artists I love the guy
neces that's hit the girl in the band
SiC rapper too and they both were like
they had a child together and they're
just like an awesome power cloud and
they're doing like cool things for in
South Africa I mean II they're yeah I
think so I think they they represent
like Cape Town like kind of like this
kind of hybrid of like I mean South
Africa me one of the most amazing places
like culturally favourite country man
yeah I love it I mean like I go there I
work a lot in Africa with like mother
project Major Lazer and like I do shows
like Nigeria we go to Uganda Kenya and
South Africa it's like a bubble like
there's it really it exists on its own
cuz it's so diverse with laughs people
music and even the scene that is like
techno music they're like African techno
African houses like African hip-hop you
know they speak and cos'è they speak
four different language they have hold
it for music sings in there Afrikaans
they like you know rock and roll it's
just the craziest most vibrant place
right hey us there I love that place so
much then if you see Cape Town they have
like these amazing communities there
they like doing like drifting and like
they're doing like these crazy it's just
it's just such a hop is our place I
wonder why well I guess because I mean
obviously they have so much African
culture they're like any time I've been
there we even went up into like into the
country like away from some of the
coastal areas and went to like some
black colleges like the
first black college ever in like some
places so I could see how they just have
their influences are just all over the
place because it's also real kind of
avant-garde like there yeah they had I
think there's like this it was always
the richest African country um
it's terrible because like you know it
was it was colonized and I think it was
you know it's this hybrid of European
like four different tribes that are
really big and South Africa then you
have like Indian culture and then like a
lot of immigrants and then the like know
like the last 20 years I mean a part
that only ended like the 90s which is
crazy and then it kind of dissolved into
like there's like chaos and Paulette the
political universe there but in general
um it's very it's a first world
countries like the infrastructure was
built during apartheid and it was always
like they had like space program you
know that they had like oh yeah eighties
they're like a space program I love to
see that I mean it's like this kind of
like sense of like I mean we just watch
die Antwoord in the movies or some of
the bits like sense of like aliens in
South Africa you know like this kind of
oh the movie he didn't believe the guys
were like at district 9 like they're
right they're part of that that
community that do that cause that's a
fool like South African film and it kind
of feels like you know a realistic
version of like how aliens it something
about refugee culture because the aliens
like refugees they're put in just like
this they're they're put in selecting
ghettos yeah
and it's like it's like if you take the
idea of race and humans out of it you
think about it from a different
perspective that's the movie it's like
kind of like you think about it in a
different way like how you know we're
actually one species humans right and
how can you like discern like the idea
of race and speed it's just like kind of
a really strong conversation because
I've ever get such a violent history and
um you know it's kind of cool now
because I think the younger generation
of kids I see when I go and play there
they're like finally post a part I like
the way they think about people in like
but if you meet people that are over 30
they still have this they still have
this sense of inbred racism in their
minds yeah but I'd have to get Rove yeah
it's racism is kind of fascinating man
because some of it is I think it's some
of it sadly I think just takes time to
go yeah because some of it isn't even
some people's fault it is
it's the payer it's the grain is
something that's like it's almost like
that Reaganomics it's hard it's hard to
change your parents minds you know like
it's just it's
weird and yes Africa like really when
apartheid broke I think it was like a
strong like they the the whole culture
chain rules change laws changed and like
broke really America's had this like
sliding dealing with racism like that's
never really gone anyway we never really
I mean we had like a civil rights
movement which which was you know people
always go back to that like that was a
big movie but really nothing when you
think about what's happening now like
nothing really has changed since then
for black Americans to where it's still
like ingrained like racism in our in our
in our society and you think about
places what is amazing about it so for
Iceland because they think about place
like Brazil even like they don't have
never had that they never had place it's
like where they had a movement right for
like black Brazilians and Brazilians of
color like change the government the way
the country is but America had it but we
just still have no we're dealing with
racism so slowly right I mean the fact
that we're still like Mississippi
I was born in Mississippi is now have
the conversation to change the
Confederate flag off their flags like
that was the Confederate flag was put on
the city's flag during like the 1890s as
like to because that was a racy time
yeah it was definitely done as like a
moment like a really racist movement and
like there's no reason to there's no
pride or heritage in that flag like for
me right I'm born Mississippi and I you
know I'm proud of him proud I was born
there but I mean there's no reason for
that symbol to mean anything to anybody
it's literally the symbol of losers and
it offends people so I don't understand
what the Cawood argument is well I think
and I can even not I can't justify the
argument but I know that I think there's
some people who just grew up with it not
being like maybe their grandparents it
was a racist thing for you know but I
think there's like younger people who
are looks like oh that means that I'm
southern or that yes they did there's a
lot of disinformation like what it does
mean like in people people experience
like what black lives matter means or
defund the police it's like a shocking
idea right in the beginning but if you
just read into it a little bit and kind
of understand the concepts you can kind
of be logical about the way you think
about it if you think about the reason
of that image it's kind of easy to
understand why it's on inclusive but if
you're born there and you just grew up
there you want hold on to that because
that's you like I understand a little
bit erudition yeah but you don't know
you don't think about oh wait that
actually is something that was
extremely racist yeah it's put into the
flag whatever so then you can feel oh
yeah that's why that's why bothers
people and then you got to realize like
is it that important to you right as it
is to them because it's actually
offensive to them for you it just means
like something they don't really
understand that it means but right for
you it's maybe something that you put up
on your wall but I think um you know cuz
I agree with you wholeheartedly you know
I know exactly what you're saying the
tough part is getting people to see that
other perspectives you're really getting
them to see it you know and also yeah I
think for a lot of people and that would
be my only argument against not against
it but for understanding like having
empathy for why some people think oh
you're taking away a piece of my
tradition you know it's just the
tradition to them not as what is the
history yeah everybody America was like
feel like the fighting the whole like
there's fighting for like hold on to
something like but it's like you gotta
understand what is it what's it really
mean if you can I wanted to find it to
yourself if you dig that deep you'll be
like oh actually you know it it's kind
of [ __ ] but you might take you while
to scratch the surface right that's a
good there and that's the thing and
that's the that's what I think um you
know it's like having empathy for people
as they figure out what's that process
and that's sometimes I think what's hard
to do between different sides it's like
you know it's you know I've been lucky
enough and you know the comfortable
place and they kind of get to another
place where you can kind of get a
different view of things even as going
to South Africa bro I remember the first
time I went to South Africa the first
country I ever went to outside of
America why did you go there for the
first time I was working on a reality
show when they took us there as a trip
oh yes that's right and I remember
getting there and I remember there were
so many weird like these Soweto villages
and stuff there's so many black people
yeah just so many and I grew up in
Louisiana it was really 5050 in our area
but I remember thinking holy smokes all
these people and there's a lot of
Christians too there and I remember you
know I believe in going to heaven and
stuff and so I remember thinking holy
smokes there's gonna be a lot of black
people in heaven I've never it's kind of
weird to conceptualize it that way it is
then I'd never thought about it you know
I guess I'd only go on mostly white
churches and you know not that I thought
heaven was only for white people but
when I saw it was just I mean some of
the Soweto villages worth tens of
thousands of people out in these like Li
shus and shane towns you
and I was like holy smokes like all
these people are gonna be in heaven too
and I'd never put that other countries
also go to heaven I think I just never I
thought heaven was just for America is
crazy thing about America that's the
most segregated place in America's
churches like literally you never see
like white and black people go to church
together yeah it's always like a defined
but Church it brings in effort yeah sure
chickens like everybody's there having a
good time but I just thought about that
it's not like a bad thing religions you
know it's organized in a certain way but
you never it's I went to church all the
time as my as the young person it was
just like our neighborhood down in
Florida or Mississippi was like like a
white church yeah and the black church
was on another side of the street or
whatever and there never was like the
black churches [ __ ] highway way more
of our life gonna go the black church
you know every once in a while
did I ever go to a black funeral and be
here like damn I want to be black man
but cuz it will do in Louisiana you have
like the most amazing funeral culture
it's like created the second line and
like jazz funerals and like wow it's
like just definitely going to heaven are
you going Sun percent you're going
somewhere way better than we are
okay I don't wanna go there and just
like a guy like going oh dude I want the
top of this I want the top of the casket
to be wet that's how I am
we had a question that came in for you
actually right here there's questions I
should not sure if our audio up or now
mm-hmm
it looks like my my nephew my feet man
what up the what up Diplo a legend man
Diplo I just wanted oh man what made you
want to drop the country album oh [ __ ]
thanks laughs yeah bump it every day
other than that may keep doing what you
do in Gang Gang
it was just I was just talking to uh to
my book to the to earnest who worked in
Morgan wall and in the car on the way
here
and we were talking about it like
growing up I lived in Nashville or a
couple years at Hendersonville and I
didn't consider myself part of like
country or now I was in the hip-hop
scene there doing stuff but um when you
grew up there's like the channels are
like 31 is CMT and then 33 is B et and
remember I gotta have school I would
watch the CMT counter country countdown
and I would watch the rap city rap
towards and I was always like the fusion
of that between commercial breaks I
switched channels I'll watch like you
know I'd see like Alan Jackson videos
and then I watched like Karis 1 or like
wu-tang and I just was like grew up with
that music everywhere and you know kids
in their trucks riding around doing the
same thing listen to the country hip-hop
and um my album isn't really a fusion of
that but I grew the last couple years
I've been like getting more and more in
the country because the artists are so
awesome and like so much good stuff
coming out of Nashville Songwriters you
know from Morgan like Chris Stapleton to
my guy startled Simpson yeah and there's
just I was like Dan this stuff's like
awesome like Maren Morris you know Kacey
Musgraves I was like getting into the
vibe a little bit and I was thinking
like what this this shouldn't be a taboo
thing to do is like work on country and
when we three made the first song Morgan
it was like very controversial for
Nashville even for him like it was a
trap record kind of night I don't even
think about that is but the drums that
fit on the record right um but it was
like never got played on country radio
we had to get it on healy yeah I got a
highway on the and still not playing a
country radio cuz they don't they think
it's to you guys is remake you mean the
one year there's a new album yeah but
it's more it's called heartless and
Morgan Wallen it's like kind of like got
a toe weights and stuff in it yeah so
yeah so it's just
but it's dream like crazy so like all
these kids are listening to it and
people are doing a tick-tock on like
this you kind of don't need the national
scene to do the country music like you
have to like a order to get in there I
felt like and I just felt like me and me
and Morgan we did this record and he
believed in me I'm so glad he gave me
this record and we did it separately we
did we stream the record and kids liked
and I think like kids are that guy's age
like high school kids and older kids are
just this this music this fusion of a
kind of like Club and hip hop and
country
which is enforced just we worked hard on
making it make sense yeah it really is a
time for that right now where people can
like I said no country is playing and we
almost having like half a million
streams and album already but it's also
interesting too because I think that
younger generations you see them they
want it to be they want to find it in an
alternative way yeah
and it's weird we get stuck in all in
ways that we kind of grew up with yeah
like you want to get it on this like I
said like we do some of the churches I
mean when you go to high school you're
like you get in with the art kids you
get in with like the the jocks you get
them like the goth kids I mean if you're
a black kid you're gonna do a certain
thing like you're gonna live with your
experiences in a neighborhood like you
might get into hip-hop it's gonna be
hard for you to get into goth music
alright metal music but some kids do it
nowadays kids don't have only the
information in their neighborhoods they
have YouTube they have tick-tock and
they're getting exposed to everything
and they make this choices about what
they want to be what they want to do
really really early like used to be kind
of like you know you have these genres
and you kind of as people you get put
into them too because of the amount of
information you get and think the last
couple years it's just there's no genres
we're like we broke that down I think
that's why it's a time or record like
this can exist you know and like you
aren't you know her you know rapper like
I think Outkast is a good example when
they came out they just broke down all
barriers and they made quality musically
made funk they made rock they made hip
hop to me like you know trap music and
they just like crush it internationally
I think that was like a good example of
what you could do you can mix everything
up together and I think that from then
on they open the door for a lot of music
just be like genre this and I've always
been a mmm like a sponsor of that you
know yeah you seem really kind of genre
list especially I feel like as you get
more into like kind of learning about
you know what you've done and where
you've gone through and like even just
of the locations that you've done a lot
of your shows like you'll do some I mean
even just saying that you've done shows
in Nigeria Tunis time if you said to
knees or not but Uganda we play like you
play like Uganda Independence Day cuz
the price I gotta do another project
called Major Lazer is just yeah we it
doesn't really it's not like a big
project in America we had a huge record
called lean on that was here a couple
years ago and like lighted up but never
really like the brand never worked it's
like Cooper guys like me my friend is
Jamaican my friend Mexican ape drums and
wall street fire we're just like this
diverse group we have dancers and we do
a show but it didn't really fit into the
trend in America where we like were able
to tour
whatever but in Africa just took off
like that project cuz I think Africa is
just a also place where you see the
fusion like you seen South Africa's like
that diverse place and like Uganda Kenya
especially we were we had these big
shows there were more people come to our
shows in Kenya than I could get in like
New York we have like 15,000 kids and
like in Nairobi our shows and we got
paid really well and then Africa's
difficult to because you have a couple
markets where you can make but Nigeria I
always go there and play for free like
the first couple times I went there
because they don't give a [ __ ] they were
just like that like the Nigeria music
scene is so enormous and it's so big and
right now it's so influential that we
had to like actually chip our way into
that and then finally had some fans
coming then we had a couple records over
that did well there and for a couple
years I just cost around like Africa and
like you know Europe for touring for
that project cuz it was those what money
was yeah and then um you know being here
quarantine and the working on the
country I was the first time where I've
had like a record connect in America
actually so I've been just pushing that
on making videos and marketing it's
really good we have a guy who works on a
different podcast called king of the
sting and he is the only black Henry
Rollins fan yeah but it's interesting to
see like that a younger generation is
not things aren't as linear you know
like we talked a lot about beige power
here that one day like we're all
hurtling towards this beige skin tone
eventually where it's like we have one
we're gonna be one person
yes globalization it's like just you
know it might be slower than you think
but it might be faster at the grow and
work towards you know one culture I mean
people we have only one YouTube right
and then today so you have a records
that can go anywhere they can get big in
Africa they can get big in China Japan
and you have like its lock it also
equalizes anybody can just upload a song
to SoundCloud or YouTube and it can go
you don't need a label you don't need
you see me because that changes the
there's not as much of that the the the
glass ceiling that your keeper you don't
need you don't need a to break through
all these doors to get to where you were
like if you're in a band back in the 60s
you first have to save up money to get a
guitar whatever learn it find people who
like guitar to become a band then your
energy
leave your song yeah divorce your wife
whatever go to Sons yeah yeah find some
money to go to studio recorded demos
it's already three years into your
project then maybe find someone to send
your demo to and then maybe
sucks almost dick at a label to get in
the door whatever that's like three and
then you need a woman in the band I just
got a it's it was so rough and it the
process took so [ __ ] long and then
maybe they'll give you a deal what's
gonna suck obviously yeah then you've
gotta force them to market your music
and maybe make it what video it's going
tour we're talking a five year process
to get your one [ __ ] song out right
now kids are like seventeen suburbs of
Fort Lauderdale have a buckin crazy-ass
haircut and a face that bang drop a
record in their [ __ ] little teeth
yeah just got to be a [ __ ] but it's
got to be a movement like for me peep
was like amazing you know I took me a
while to like get into music I became a
huge fan and like xxx notation other guy
was just like I was like these guys are
like doing it from the heart really like
even with riffraff in beginning you just
feel like it's really raw and real
because they didn't have any it's almost
like folk music they had no background
to do it they just dropped what they
feel like they could do and it was like
people and kids connected with it like
wow yeah they would even be fun like
really [ __ ] up making the music
sometimes I mean riff raff I couldn't
[ __ ] make it longer than without a
bag cocaine it was a [ __ ] we had a
studio and there was a painting I got
like a gold record on the wall he he
[ __ ] dug a hole behind the painting
and hid cocaine this I was like where's
the coke coming from my you always had a
bad cocaine hidden in a wall socket
somewhere and I was like and without the
cocaine he would be like trying to write
lyrics like what the [ __ ] and then with
a coke go in the booth 16 [ __ ] verses
just drop it on like left and right so
not to say you should do cocaine but for
some people it just helped a little bit
look it's Florida look that's considered
a hobby in Florida and it's a little wet
that's the thing about that Florida
cocaine man it's how they got a little
damp on the top it's crazy the different
places where drugs are so accessible
like Florida yeah Cook was like people
in high school were just doing it me now
and you know it's the kids are doing
nowadays but I don't know if kids are
doing as much I wanted to I want to tell
the refresh story too because it is so
much fun there's something about him
it's like seeing the only it's like
somebody knows where there's like a
frickin like hippopotamus and they're
not telling anybody else you know he's
like he's just like and if you get its
he not a career long career nama he's
been like doing this like 10 years and
you going that you tube down the hole
Donal would go over there for like a
week yeah
is crazy XD if we cut up a mango for me
man he said he was changing his diet
mangos only he told me I've seen him go
through a lot of different diets man he
was on a drug bending WWF diet once oh
yeah he's I think he's vegan though he's
last couple years I mean he's in sugar
so I think he's doing good for him yeah
last time I saw him he was getting more
and that was more the the vibe he was
going for I took him to the premiere of
that movie um game changers which is a
movie about Arnold Schwarzenegger
produced in the James Cameron it's a
movie about likes at the how you don't
know this but the best athletes in the
world are vegan and they have been for a
while i colitis wait let the guy was
like the strong man of the world like
the biggest weightlifter this guy
Armenian guy he's vegan the best female
like bike riders being in the best track
runners are vegan and I don't suggest
ivory be vegan cuz I think it's just you
know you got I know that's interesting
though that's interesting but when
you're doing when you're doing yeah that
guy is vegan here I got that bomb you
can actually get big Iranian song but
he's he looks awesome got the sickest I
mean if you get the mullet and those
sideburns no the Icelandic guy gots a
beast he's like seven foot tall the
other guy but that guy he's apparently
the biggest weightlifter and he's vegan
huh yeah the Chris Paul was they were
talking about a new diet that Chris Paul
was doing I think it was vegan in
Houston and Chris was at the time of the
battle player yeah he was the premier so
is DeAndre Jordan who also he's
hilarious he's big
yay Texas he actually was the high
school of it with the riffraff did he
really I think the biggest ones they
recognized you know what riffraff has
the best reason so I'll pull I'll get
there so I go into the garage he shows
me all the clothes that I owned from
1991 right there his but yeah actually
they could have been my child of the
clothes he just happen to have him in a
box at his house right he probably could
still wear him it makes sense of Elkins
bro he had all just every anything that
ever color yeah anything anything with
the Air Jordan like more colors and like
totally all of that in the box then he's
like let's go for a ride so he give me
this pretty cool Bice was it a bicycle
yes like a motorized bike and he got on
a four-wheeler and we literally went
through his neighbor's they gave me a
bison and I wrote it right I was like we
do some coke
the body some went and bought a couple
grams while I was on it that's a big
bankroll that body said yeah like I
don't know Joe nobody miss me
brotherbrother coke to bear yeah there's
a there's a bunch of coke maybe you look
up the cokes up bears another good story
a guy was like drug dealing and like
pain crashed and he was like the drug
trafficking in Kentucky and a bear found
all this coke and ate all of it and he
was like he ate like a pound of cocaine
but and then they found this bear and
they found he was like just raging and
coke in the forest and he died within
like 20 minutes yeah but they've
taxidermy he's like in a state hall or
something like the craziest coke bear
there is Pablo Escobar
what he died he did the most coke of any
animal of all time
disappear uh does Nic Cage now open this
back I feel like he would buy you
probably I'd say snort some of the Bears
hair probably God yeah what about
Swilley I saw you had him on at Mon no
he's from Tupelo as well yes Whaley
actually my only show ever did in
Mississippi was in Tupelo they just do
this they used to do that Christmas at
the casino where now how was it it was
in a um it was in a like there must be a
basketball arena for there's a
university around there or something it
was like ten thousand capacity maybe
northwestern Louisiana or so it was no
it wasn't it was in Tupelo like there's
like a little tiny arena there they had
myself country shows and things like
that to show there and honestly bro that
show gave me a lot of faith in
Mississippi because I mean I'm from
Mississippi they're both from Tupelo the
brothers and then you know Elvis was
born and oh yeah hello
we went to his childhood home on our
last tour we stopped over there the home
he was born in Memphis I think they they
they the the guys who sold him his first
guitar can in my show they had like
another museum there and they he's the
bike hardware stores just used to so
musicians instruments back in the 50s I
guess that's where you buy in a music
shop so you'd go to a hardware store and
have a guitar up there and they had a
his hardware store came and gave me like
a bunch of memorabilia and stuff but
that crowd was like I mean he was weirdo
segregated like there was the groups of
kids in there for high schools but it
was like the first thought thing this
would be ever had a show that was like
equally wide Atlantic kids are just knew
every lyric to every song and you know
I'm glad to
kids even knew the [ __ ] I was I was like
up there DJing with them but it was the
the mayor came out and gave me the key
to say that's awesome and raise rumors
come at me never skids are amazing
they're like I'll cast to me like
they're they're also like a like I said
kids I don't they don't have her [ __ ]
rules
like they grew up like probably listened
to everything in sways voice is amazing
we did a bunch of right we did a record
with a ellie goulding called close to me
that went yeah yeah yeah I heard that
man yeah there we were right there yeah
that was in Tupelo actually so that was
the home that yeah that Elvis was born
and we just stopped there on the last
tour man yeah I'm a big guy was fan yeah
man attention but then they also say
that nine that we brought the gob last
time some of his to some of his songs
were bought off of a black back then I
think a lot of times they were he was
definitely ripped everything off of yeah
black rockabilly you know like early
rock artist name sure the johner was
back then but I mean he was he had like
5,000 songs like some amazing I'm in the
beginning I'm sure he had black
songwriters he wrote some stuff at Sun
Studios would like you know Johnny Cash
even and um most other guy used to write
was his records uh another another East
Tennessee guy wailing yeah but I mean he
was I mean everybody knows that Elvis
story I mean he was definitely uh no it
was it was in Sun Studios there's a
picture of Johnny Cash Elvis and Carl
Carl Perkins
and there's like the four of these guys
it was like an amazing vibe in that
studio but um you said you want me
Johnny I mean Elvis has a oh he still
look very people loved this picture sick
look at this guy Million Dollar Quartet
it's Carl Perkins yes right and Elvis
got them baby cheeks almost a kiss but
skin on his face
it's a beautiful face nice this early
looks like I got Botox back in
Mississippi style Jerry Lee Lewis really
Louis yeah that guy was a freaking well
he's from Louisiana
he wouldn't that guy would have made it
these days marrying a 13 sister in
Hollywood he's still my baby no he
actually it ruin his career he actually
flew to Europe and it just became like a
it was like a early like tabloid thing
and he couldn't really get past it
Wow yeah he was him and uh him and
Richard Richard a little richer had this
crazy [ __ ] beef like they were like
they were like they were like always
like asking
good headline the shows and I remember
like it was always like play shows again
I was like who's gonna who's the
headliner and at one point either he or
Richard just set the whole panel on fire
yeah and I walked offstage because they
open for one of them and then I think
they became friends in the end like in
the eighties they did a song together
but there was like a beef that's
gangster breath because they were both
like this piano rocking southern dudes I
mean oh yeah man he's from 30 Louisiana
I think I saw him about five years ago
actually at his daughter sang a couple
of the songs but he would come out for
like every other one that would kind of
wheel him out you know fire and play so
it story Jerry that was set piano fire
yeah that's like the good old days and
when you do a show and you're so mad
probably [ __ ] drunk as [ __ ] and your
[ __ ] you I don't know kind of drugs you
doing but then quaaludes or something
right no you see you see walk hard that
movie with john c reilly yeah Oh Mike
you gotta watch it it's one of the
[ __ ] best music documentaries about
it's fake but basically john c reilly
does everything like invents country
events like palm convent's like he just
he's brian wilson and a lot of yeah
force companies like he kind of dude the
Johnny Cash saw the Train cash movie car
I walked all walked all and they called
isn't it make fun of that but john c
reilly does every genre and like is this
crazy country guy and have like 100 kids
by the end of the movie does every drug
yeah by the movie those days you were
pulling up in talent somebody literally
somebody to say hey these are drugs and
it would just be like almost it'll be so
funny cuz it was like he walks into the
back room in his home what's that what's
the black comedian at SNL guy like Tim
Meadows
Cyn Meadows every time he walks in the
backstage Tim I was like smoking weed
he's like what are you doing Tim I was
like it's marijuana man you don't want
to do this yeah like what he's like what
does it do it makes you feel happy and
you melt you out you feel great you
don't want to do this he's like I think
I want this marijuana and he does that
and then the next like 10 years ladies
like what we do and he's like it's
called cocaine but what does it do it
was like oh no man it's do you want this
it makes you feel great and excited I'll
try to cocaine this is like heroin that
like three years later it's like
addictive it already looks like it looks
like Jim Morrison in the pictures look
at that I'll bring you gotta watch the
movie it's my favorite movie of all time
Wow dude now gotta watch I just watch
uncut Jim's last night that's dark bro
it was good though
I wanted the guy to die so bad man
because he just wanted to pain this yeah
he just never had it and everything's no
way there's no way this is gonna end
well you just know like you wanted to
get back with his wife then you but the
side girl was hot and then you wanted to
win but you know you're never gonna win
and then anything you wanted didn't then
he does in any way oh [ __ ] this came
together and he dies oh yeah the last
Jim gets cut but there was awesome by
the movie bro is the [ __ ] soundtrack
is phenomenal and I think it was a
unique way to do a soundtrack it wasn't
it was sound that I felt like there's my
perception it was sound that made me
feel comfortable yes and it made me it
was like sound that tried to get me just
through small sounds repetitive beats to
get me feel a certain way one of my
favorite musicians of all time is Hans
Zimmer and I love Blade Runner and the
new Blade Runner I loved even more and
the soundtrack was so [ __ ] amazing I
loved ambient music I loved that kind of
like futuristic music and the guy who
did the soundtrack I think his name is
100 point tricks this is ambient guy and
he just the fact that the director went
with that guy to make a movie and he
just it's so it felt so wrong that when
he when it's in the movie this is the
weird like since but then he just yeah
it really puts you on edge on the on the
right level for you to be uncomfortable
watching them yeah yeah I never felt
like that I never felt like what's I'm
watching the movie I'm enjoying it but
also something else is happening to me
and what is it what is causing that and
yeah it was just it was because
soundtracks are really difficult to do
and like to make you have to watch the
film and like put it in you know you
gotta kind of close get closure with the
whole film coming together with the
sound and that guy he crushed and I'd
love that although that I love the
soundtrack more than the film actually
listened back to it
have you been pushed to do soundtrack
you'd be done him before nah but that
made that movie made me want to do it
because I am during quarantine I haven't
really worked on a lot of new music
I've been putting out this comes from
their country stuff and working on some
house music but I just don't don't first
you don't wanna do sessions because this
isn't really do you don't really want to
get anybody you know sick or whatever
you don't get sick but then I don't feel
like you can't really sit down during
this weird time it feels a little more
like less heavy than it did in March and
April now even though slightly worse I
guess but there's other cases but yeah
the vibe is a little different now it is
I feel there's a anxiety attack feeling
you know like you don't feel like you
feel like there's some and they're gonna
be end
right like simply film people getting
out of it like New York City for
instance beat this thing you know so we
can do it but in the beginning I was
like I had like a lot anxiety attacks
and just fell like weird you don't wanna
like write a song about like a love song
you don't feel you can't write a pop
song during all that vibes the energy is
not right so I was writing a lot of
ambient music I was just like doing
stuff with sand sand making these
records that are just like Spacey and
like no drums and I did a whole EP then
I'll drop at some point that just made a
slow thing I've done during quarantine
is like that kind of music just sounds
yeah sounds like kind of but you got it
it's like kind of classical music but
with since like I mean that's kind of
what neoclassical music and ambient
music is it's like you you put chords
together and you kind of build things up
with like arpeggiators and then you you
know Brian Eno it all knew him he
produced on u2's Joshua Tree and he's
like an ami an artist but he kind of
combined these new ideas of sound with
pop records back in the 80s and it's
amazing I wouldn't consider him a
composer but it's like yeah it's like
being composed and I guess doing this
kind of music rather than that do you
get like a little bit jealous whenever
you see somebody like do something like
a loophole or something or crowd of let
me start to see the new thing you're
like oh yeah and that's how you work on
music I just been I'm a producer more
than an artist you know I think with
this with the country album is the first
time I've done like a full artist record
on a major label but before that I've
always been like Beyonce want a record
uh sure wants a record you know a rock
band wants a record or I work in the
studio with different writers and
propose ideas and I come up with
concepts that's what a producer does it
kind of like you work with the artist
and you think like google riff raff you
like how can I make what I like about
this guy how can I make the best version
of him that's what you do with anybody
maybe it's Madonna maybe it's a Adele
whatever it is you know you aim for the
biggest records the big artists then you
work with something like riff raff to
just like this is it [ __ ] awesome
like this is something really cool when
that lovely does or sway Lee and you you
know you can find new artists too but as
a producer your job is to create
concepts and you know and I maybe not
even writing the piano like you can be
like Rick Rubin and just sit back and
just like just fine-tune that idea with
the Chili Peppers but is it hard to
figure out though like sometimes I find
even for myself from doing comedy and
doing just different types of things
within the world is it hard to figure
out what what some of your real strong
suits
and then to focus on those even if those
went against like yeah like sometimes
somebody you know I mean I was gonna be
the star sometimes but then you're like
oh man but I'm so good at this but the
this weird idea of a star always I've
never been really good at anything even
playing music I mean I've always been
like like I said I would come up with
like we're I find the the loopholes
where the no one was doing stuff like
Major Lazer started cuz like no one was
making this like reggae and dancehall
music you know and I had done stuff with
this girl in MI a was like my girlfriend
a time I made amazing records oh damn
dude and I went to a mic this is cuz
it's full circle really quick i defer i
saw john c reilly a dan in my a concert
in New Orleans at the it was it started
like a House of Blues no this was in
like a warehouse or something it was
like 4:00 a.m. I started but anyway DJ
for a lot of shows back in those days
but we did this fusion she was an artist
that really put me on to like how far
you could go with just ideas and she had
these ideas and she [ __ ] crushed it
and I I learned a lot from her and I
think we started like this major laser
thing cause I was like no one's doing
this we could do it in a different way
like dancehall records in reggae because
no one's doing it and it took a while we
made some big records and and then they
grew it just but it wasn't something no
one was doing yeah and then back then no
one was even streaming music you know as
we worked really hard in the streaming
services because a lot of the majors
were not really pushing streaming
they're still fighting to sell physical
copies and I didn't all independently we
did it on our own and I learned a lot
from there but I think you find little
projects like that people don't do is
sometimes you take risks and they don't
work I had my first album I producers a
band called on Rollo Tomassi and it was
a fully metal math rock band I didn't
know what I was doing but his Didache
says the guy that does my first job and
then the next day I was working with
Bruno Mars I'm feeling like he was a
songwriter back then when I first moved
to LA I just did whatever jobs I had you
just make your way up to where you could
hopefully place a big record with
somebody need to learn a lot like I
learned everything from coming to LA and
leaving behind the idea of being artists
and being like a producer in the game
here and then and then as I got better
at that I kind of got sick of that like
I don't know why records other people
right and I started doing my own little
projects and then and just being
creative yeah because you know doing a
project writing the music is for me I
think it's like 20% of the project the
other 80% is coming up with the concept
in the marketing and like what it is
video things like you think
the name of the style the way you can
address this project you kind of come up
with these you create the artists and
that's that's 80% of what artists are
nowadays oh four in my opinion you have
to come up with like a real brand right
now and that's what people get first the
music comes secondly like if you see
someone like this fascinating like what
is this and you dig into it you're like
oh that's a great example yeah he's all
brand I mean he was just like his music
is great too but it was all brand but
another like marshmallow another guy you
know like he's a DJ and I think oh yeah
he's yeah they might be like 90% brand
cuz he's just like the concept is so
strong what he does it's so easy to
identify with and then he puts our
quality music as well like it's ease pop
artists but I mean he no other DJ could
do that because they're just another guy
yes a marshmallow right kids can
gravitate to that really easy and I
think what he did is a great marketing
campaign from the jump his manager and
him really crushed that you him he came
run have that great uh yeah their
country record that great song yeah um
you know I had that record originally
that he sent it to me like I actually
was like Texan canes like man it was
like me and marshmallow fighting for
that record actually in the beginning so
it's gonna be something for my project
and then um I lost the battle oh that's
whatever came Brown he stole me record
bro yeah man I love came Brown yeah um
you know New Orleans when I was growing
up a lot of the artists over there were
like the big timers and uh you know
little white dwarfs that hip-hop
revolution the New Orleans episode uh uh
I need a great this whole I'm gonna
agree watch this whole episode and write
down all the things I don't want anyone
starts with like Master P and M in New
Orleans for me bro it's the first black
thing Memphis it has the longest
cultural significance in hip-hop right
people can argue me but like when you
think about what music sounds like now
hip-hop it all comes back to this
Memphis sound like this aggressive this
dark and the trap beats and like it's
just lasted forever and it was a small
flash tin pan with three six and like
8ball & MJG were doing it and the New
Orleans was like the same kind of sound
and it's an electronic drum sound they
like blood the electro they loved like
many freshers and they can you know like
these kind of like 808 sounds and they
mix it with the second lion jazz and
then Big Tymers and then Master P came
up with the idea of independent label
and he [ __ ] crushed in and it's cash
money came out and then and had this
amazing bounced
I love someone mad so I was gonna get to
it about scene because uh yeah like Big
Freedia like some of the Artemis she's
the most popular but the bounce scene
there has been probably the biggest
thing it's come out and it's never
laughs and it's the same Rio Frieda I
was I worked with this um I worked a
couple bounce artists there's flyboy ki
know there's Cissy know be it's it's
very gay
it's crazy people realize how gay the
hip-hop scene in New Orleans is a lot of
the rappers and labels you know you talk
to like mr. cool or like these guys I
was with I was a mystic on the studio
know and after got at jail and I had
just on this record called express
yourself with um Nicki to be who was
another gay bounce artist from New
Orleans and um it's like my fusion of
like dance music in New Orleans bounce
back then and I'm never playing it from
mystical in the studio I was like man
can you jump on a super game the video
was gay too and I was like can you jump
on this record and you know mystical
said to me was like bro that's hard
that's actually New Orleans music and he
knew that's like that's acts at the
scene he wasn't like homophobic or
anybody's like man I just can't come out
of jail and do it like this record right
now I can't really like do a verse on a
gay bowser Eckerd but um I'll be right
but but at the same time he had respect
and like knew that that's like real New
Orleans music cuz if you don't realize
like even the you know big Frida's in
that record with Drake that came out
last year because of Drake's last album
had a lot of bounce influences all New
Orleans records on it but there's not
there hasn't been a that there hasn't
been a strong hip hop's been the only
our bounces been the only real music to
come out of that area kind of I feel
like there's that one interesting
nineties
oh you mean not third a third I've three
goes down something like that Reaser
studio when I worked on music with them
oh I don't you talking about they're
nice guys - yeah that's my other thing I
was really I remember wrong there's
nothing there's a jam man from New
Orleans oh dude
one of them owns a freaking restaurant
where I'll take my stepdad all the time
and I mean if you get if you want to
learn for me meters is Funk and country
completely mastered majesty their font
but they're like country road
and they're instrumental like meters are
like wife they're like one of my biggest
influences of all time like they're so
dope like a New Orleans funk is just
like gonna learn about music New Orleans
is the birth of all American music in my
opinion Wow like everything comes from
New Orleans you know from the history of
like it's the perfect combination of
African music and European music and go
bat no that's not dog something look at
indie band New Orleans maybe an indie
band indie rock New Orleans but there
hasn't been a reason why there hasn't
been a strong hip-hop artists that's
come out of there in a while I mean you
think there would be so well there's
like others in the NBA young boy from
Baton Rouge dad's name was that sure
he's might be the biggest oh there's
also there's Kevin gates yeah and be
young boys from that is he from Baton
Rouge I mean he's like one of the
biggest like low-key yeah yeah he like
low-key he's one of the biggest figures
and hip hop around even no one named a
young boy song but like he just every
girl knows him it was music he just is
always loving and booty but he lives in
Atlanta yeah boo see is that guy just
came out of jail like he was like he
missed all technology and then just came
what is it so great he and he denied it
I asked him we cause he came and I asked
him I said do you think that because you
were in jail you missed kind of like the
evolution of Technology so you came into
Instagram we're just way too real I was
so ready
it didn't register for him but I thought
that's exactly that he got out and his
like friends gave us iPhones like what
is this like he was like it was like
literally came out of jail like went for
it was he missed the the clutch parts of
technology yep and just came back like
insane like he's a legend now anybody
you come back to him a lot of people
like if you do like that dirty hip-hop
he he's the guy and that's I don't know
much about Baton Rouge I know I only
went there wants to actually went to
little boo see I did a uh I was in Baton
Rouge for like my birthday I had nothing
I go on I was in New Orleans for my
birthday when I like turn like 24 I just
went by myself to like read and just I
loved Louisiana I just like go to bars
and stuff and I had a friend there and
we went to see [ __ ] did a concert at a
mall in Baton Rouge night when Thomas
before he went to jail and that's the
only time we were in Baton Rouge was go
see boo see an awesome dude when he left
it was one of the first times I ever
felt like man I wish he was still here
like I'd be scared as [ __ ] they have
told you before he came be so scared
Glenn Davis was on he's a basketball
player big baby he played for the
Celtics and he came on he's like you
guys big baby please pay for the
Clippers a while yeah any play for 14
Dorsey Florida all he played at LSU LSU
yeah there's like a Demetrius Demetrius
something's not a big giant Center like
fat passel player it was called the
meathook oh yeah big baby was a was not
he didn't look out letting but he was a
clipper we loved him he when he scored
points we were just the crowd went crazy
for love
oh he's extremely lovable he has such a
good he's not look like a Mousehole
player honestly nobody he's 75 percent
heart you know
Dimitri Hill is a oh he was big too I
member watching him play but he loves me
and he lives in Las Vegas now he loves
being actually he just hit me up after
Dustin Poirier won that fight and they
ended up connecting man oh there you go
oh that's them is that that's me just if
they forgot your Gators remember that
yeah yeah here's a big boy dang it's
always fun when you see them big do it
huh it's always fun man Jack was big too
but he ended up he wasn't really that
must he was he's built like a big giant
human being a lot of the stairs are not
like that not was yeah they really don't
had that center position anymore Shaq in
college jacket LSU he was leaning like
you man he was long me who uh who's that
Lakers player sits like cut you say
please don't like him or maybe Rockets
Dwight Howard he just like oh here's
like buff basketball player he's a model
I feel like I felt like he's more of a
model look at the baby Shaq um you look
at young man I deejay with Shaq
sometimes he's like really yeah he's
played his podcast this week on he did
like a stream and he just
this guy's [ __ ] dedicated to DJ him
bro and he [ __ ] loves it he's a
dubstep DJ nice most aggressive DJ I've
ever seen my life he just goes
Betances in it before quarantine every
show he did he would go out in the
audience to hang out everybody in the
audience and he just Kassim he's like
towers of everybody but he's just like
what is it you think that he that he
that he just he really loves doing it or
he he loves the vibe remember her talk
to them because he's just happiness bro
he just loves he just found a lot of
like contentment and like happiness
after the game I think he became you
know he's a sports commentator and just
he just smart and awesome look at this
guy bro crowd Jesus I love it so crazy
outside lands like he's one of the most
aggressive deejays ever look at him you
came with Fitness dude so that's what it
looks like when you're in there huh yeah
I like that
looks does it always feel like sometimes
like like I noticed on stage if I'm
doing stand-up off I can feel a crowd I
can feel what's going on it's almost
like at some points it took a long time
but I feel like it's like that's when
you get in the pocket like I'm an
orchestra I am when you're good too at
that point you can just like you say it
like then you just flow right yeah just
feel right that yeah yeah well I can
there's a can
energy connection there's a in the
beginning it's this nervous other energy
works like I'm trying to make sure I'm
doing my job
yeah and then later it becomes this
energy where it's like oh I'm
orchestrating the the feeling of this
environment yeah is it what is it what
does that feeling like when you guys are
doing your job I think when you DJ it's
always it's it's even more
understandable have to really feel the
rhythm of the crowd I've even picked the
records you're playing me I'm a more of
a I'm more of an open format DJ so I can
kind of do it whatever I kind of
improvise a lot of people just go there
concerts and it kind of the setlist you
know what I do that when I'm headlining
some work stuff to program my lights but
mostly I'm in Vegas I'm like doing three
hours I'm just like looking at the crowd
and playing records I want to play and
then go I'm like trying to go they're
like you know what the jokes maybe you
go maybe it's not funny but you want to
push even controversy which is probably
hard really hard for comedians and me to
us walk the line now but you want to go
as contra so then you pull back whatever
so I think with me as DJ you still you
want to like sneak things in and like
okay that's wrong that's what that's
what DJ's that's what we've always been
we've always
the people to push the boundaries where
the where the where the where the the
purest form of the distribution chain
like music happens and we're the ones
that give to people in the nightclub or
somewhere where they can feel the music
for real like because you can't really
feel it in your car on the radio you
might get pop records we we make dance
music and hip-hop to where we are our
job is to is to push it as far as we can
to be the best DJs
well it's interesting it makes me think
almost like if I'm in a supermarket you
got the area where everything is like in
the boxes and it's all boxed and pack is
perfectly for you then you got that
produce area that's less you might find
an orange in a [ __ ] area that's the
real food yeah but you know I grew up my
sister I'm never going to eat at her
house like when I was back in town and
she only eats canned vegetables till we
grew up like that and she has it's and I
don't it's always like the public's cans
are like [ __ ] what's the other shitty
yes Albertsons or Piggly Wiggly and she
just doesn't ever been in the produce
section you know what it is you know
what a green bean looks like it was like
oh that's wet in a [ __ ] can what is
that thing I was like she's like green
beans look like this and I'm like okay
my family would just only eight caddy
cans I don't know what and my mom well I
think it was just that time period - it
was okay I think it poses and yeah you
know what produce section didn't really
exist in like the 80s you might get some
app bag apples or whatever bag apples
you want to select your own apples no
that's no the government's gonna select
those apples for you and I'm sorry yeah
knew each other for they guys you know
you gonna feel those apples here's your
bag [ __ ] growing cropping I'm
like I want to go to produce in like
buying [ __ ] but when I was younger you
never
mom didn't let you go over there yeah
that's for the liberal sorry shopping
producer doesn't you have a white nobody
needs to pick their own pineapple that's
good government does that for you let's
get a question right here
I was just got talking about he's
driving the demo shaman does go now
you're a remix of projects hope you guys
are doing great in real quickly I'm
sporting my Wow throw down baby
bear down dip oh I just had a question
for you would you ever consider doing a
fresh banger with our boy - conscious
six nine now that he's out of out of
jail at all
I know that you would love that I much
huge six my fan honestly his music bro
he puts the music out and I wait for it
I even show up at the time yeah he's
having a lot of Instagram live I got to
stop the car
and why should I mean honestly he's the
first just the fact that he broke down I
mean I just love him just from being
just a [ __ ] biggest punk ass there is
oh she's like I'd love all that I love
that hip hop had this like kind of its
kind of boring now it's kind of like
there's the older guy they don't go away
and they kind of like talk about the
same [ __ ] I think beef and yeah they're
all [ __ ] beef and he's actually just
[ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] you here's your beers
there's a picture you being a [ __ ] and
like yeah he's not scared to anybody and
I just love that he just kind of
deconstructed hip-hopping away and
people are like then one can kill him
it's like impossible I don't know you
came and bothered the guy I just was
wearing the brightest in the whole world
and he just has all he's like yeah the
other side but I'm rainbow hair guy and
you what the [ __ ] were you mad at me I
mean I just love that he any any and he
didn't have the number one with that
with this for the first thing I'll out
of jail and then he learned how to do it
and he did the you know tied in with the
sales of the clothes and the physical
and just it's all big [ __ ] hack at
this point yeah hacked it and he like he
learned from it and got the number one
and everybody
[ __ ] everybody I love the actual [ __ ]
you that everybody that he did and he
came and did it yeah so I love him and I
would I'd love to work in my nose I know
him his his uh his label head really
well we worked on ideas back before he
went to jail and I'm having connected
with him since then but uh I last felt
not really doing hip hop right now but I
would do something with him just cuz I
love him as an artist yeah and that's
controversial people very like something
that that sucks but I just I [ __ ]
[ __ ] with him hard yeah yeah no I feel
you man I do - dude I'm like and I love
how there's all these haters that he's a
guest it's almost like this invisible
world you know that he's created is real
renegade okay well even when you said
deconstructed I'd know I'd always heard
people say I'm a deconstruct something
but I never kind of knew what they were
talking about but just now when you said
that it there yeah because hip-hop has
this sort of like you think about these
rules needs little thing and you just
gotta like embarrass this buddy to like
kind of like people had people actually
don't be for them they're scared of him
now because you can't win because he'll
just do whatever you can there's no
rules for him you know he's got and then
he gets Nicki Minaj in which is crazy
cuz they're always fighting over who's
Nicki Minaj's boyfriend but she she was
with him on the record Fifi you back in
the day I think she does also loves his
she's very controversial too you know
she'll say whatever the [ __ ] she wants
and I got a record coming out with her
real and Major Lazer this month and I
love her and I honestly I worked to her
a couple times and she is a [ __ ] hard
worker bro
he will E yeah we're never really been a
fan she as a rapper lyrically I mean
she's like no one's don't get touch her
I feel like and then at the same time
like I we did the song together and she
went back and forth like I'm just like
small song you know maybe it'll be big
she's like like the record she did it
for me she likes me I think
but she just went back in the studio
like four times I could I didn't ask her
to say I won't change this part when
she's just part and she went like a
bunch of times asked me my my advice on
it and I'm real proud she's a real
collaborator and she does it like her
and Madonna or two women that were just
like they work harder than me and that's
hard I feel like I work pretty hard so
they both like it sounds like a man I
wish that they could take your brain
whenever you pass and just splice it in
like they're literally hallways of a
library where people could walk through
and see what you might be some stuff in
there man I don't know if you want to
open that up define where you can some
double doors remember at the back in the
day they used to have a video store and
they would have the double doors where
the code I would sneak in there growing
up in Florida like I was gonna my
grandma's house my parents are just drop
me off there like [ __ ] that can't afford
summer camp or nothing I had nothing to
do they were just driving four hours of
new smartness little small-town drop me
Graham
and I could only walk in my little Santa
live dirt roads in Florida we have sand
roads Wow I would walk [ __ ] mile to
the video store my grandma gave me like
five dollars I would just rent every WWF
video I watch every wrestle me because I
never paid for the pay-per-views I'll
watch like the last five years old I
watch like one summer watch like 500
Wessling contests and in every kung fu
movie there was I just that found the
porn area
oh yeah couldn't rent those without go
I'd go back I go right I go see those
boxes right I mean just awkward it's
like going to the point
renting Eminem and stand in front of
somebody and have like a stack of like
these dirty pornos like but dude there's
almost more of a respect there there's a
line in the sand where you're like okay
am i me doing this or not doing this or
not yeah now it's too easy access oh
yeah like you can be it's too much
privacy back in there you're freaking
pervert we're gonna see ya outside
there's always a sex shop too that has
like the pornos and like in Philly
there's like this one little area they
probably cleaned it up since I was
living there but there was one little
area where they had like this shops
where you just go and you could just
jerk off and like watch a girl behind a
glass and they would do things yeah
there's like this is like shops and then
you go there's video stores there's the
photos for me in New York had that [ __ ]
- I don't see idea of the sex the sex
shops doesn't even like thing anymore
not pool on hookers I'm talking about
like you were just like and I see a real
woman through glass yeah yeah did that
in one episode I never seen that
anywhere else though she would just do
things kinda like what it I guess what a
a chat was called now the camera would
do yeah I'm real but they're the next
ones over there in Philly were probably
pretty dude I remember this now you made
me think of it this one time I was in
Amsterdam and so they had a thing you go
in this little cage kind of in
everybody's glass opens up and they
there's a wheel there's like a lazy
susan in there and it has people and
there's like a man and a woman having
sex and everybody's then you can see
everybody you see everybody else how
about there it would be a mirror to see
awkward that's the mirror you guys
already like so you realize you go you
got to look right at the cup you can't
be spraying visually and then the crazy
part was everybody else's slides went
down after they were done after yeah
fifteen minutes whatever mine wooden
didn't go down or something so I had
watching the couple who are now dizzy
from the things spin and help each other
it's like when you keeping your kid on a
little their little face with the park
and you let your kid walk away kind of
drunk one of his ears eyes forty rounds
do you know you've done so much with
music over the years and especially so
much I think with diverse let's get a
question right here this guy actually
looks diverse let's get him in all right
whatever kept here from Toronto dimple
Oh where'd you rather party Trinidad or
Jamaica so good answer that's a tough
one what's he gonna be I'm gonna say
Trinidad
he's probably trainee looks like he's
from Toronto has a big like Trini vs
Laura but I just had a baby in Trinidad
with my ex-girlfriend and uh well she's
like my no she's an awesome girl and I
haven't seen the baby because I I was
gonna go there in March for a show and
stay there for a month and then I've
been we try to travel man I have to
quarantine in Trinidad and so I would go
to Trinidad I I need to go there as soon
as possible but the city itself Port of
Spain China is like people don't know
this but it's kind of like this kind of
problem with the wealthiest Caribbean
countries has good surf has this amazing
music culture but it has this crazy
mash-up of like you know European
African Indian just kind of all like
living there and little working in this
crazy music scene of course soca
they have reggae dancehall I used to do
parties there Major Lazer had to show
there every December and it was at this
water park and it was like the crazy
show we'd had like people on shoulders
like water flowing everywhere like crowd
doing all the different dances together
and I mean turned out of just legend day
and I miss going there to do shows but
um to get a chance to check out Trinidad
man a place for Carnival I think it's
like in the end of February same time
right before Mardi Gras so you can
actually I did a tour last year I did I
did I did um or two years ago I did I
did carnival in Brazil had a show and
sure I went to turned out to see that
see the carnet do a show there and then
went straight to Mardi Gras
and did all the the circuit basically
because it's all around the same right
holiday so what was that vibe like was
there like that obviously they must have
different from each one percent the the
the the carnival in in Brazil is just
like the Super Bowl I mean there's like
a Samba drum they have their own stadium
just for the carnival floats and it's
just the music is insane it's like the
whole country parties at once it's just
so sexualized and beautiful at the same
time everybody's so [ __ ] happy and
then Mardi Gras we've been in New
Orleans just like just [ __ ] trash
like in the next level
[ __ ] but we had this really awesome
pop off from one of the other I love it
so much so I'd love I actually went to
see some of the floats a car at Mardi
Gras for the first time cuz I've been
there for parties and I was like Danny's
floats are awesome like all the
different yeah they're really cool it
was such a lower level but I'm like you
see like the black community floats and
like the second line they say the white
people are doing that the things and
they just it's it's like the one thing
everybody's kind of is together yeah on
the side of the roads and seeing
everything and I played a party with a
good friends of mine band called Arcade
Fire you know those guys yeah when
Butler is the the lead band guy and he's
he also bass low player and he has a
party there called carnival crew and it
was amazing it was like drag queens and
like we had um choppa played with me and
Aleya he DJ there's our Haitian band
playing Haitian music and it was like
just like this really like multi quote
it was like amazing party and just like
the most inclusive party you could have
a New Orleans like there's a lot of that
there that's what that's that place is
kind of anything that's why I'm saying
like the bounciness is gay the city
itself is so DIY like kids go there like
punk kids a lot of punk bands like in
New Orleans and like punk kids they go
there and they bring in a warehouse
space and they have a little commune and
they build they make their own little
restaurants or whatever and it's like
you don't have myself [ __ ] up I think
Katrina might have done the most work to
preserve the culture of of New Orleans
because right before Katrina happen it
really felt like no one was was destined
to be this big destination and like
people buying property and hotels were
coming in their restaurants and the
Katrina just wiped out all the
investment like in a way and people left
there's like like 400,000 people in
before Katrina 200,000 left yeah and and
the city had to start over again but
what didn't stop what didn't stop was
that all
cultural movement didn't really end and
it just got bigger and more it's
isolated you know and you might the
isolation in China to build sometimes I
think Isis think New Orleans for me is
is like the my favorite place in the
world to go all over the world cuz it's
a spontaneous and crazy and you don't
know what's gonna happen
yeah I love that I love that well you
know it's so interesting he's talked you
talked about the the investment side of
it it's funny like you know something
really unique and special can start
somewhere
be it a festival will be it like a vibe
anything but then eventually money comes
in because they want to own it stuff in
the area they want to make it bigger
yeah and then it kind of like it it
weakens stuff over time you know but
it's so funny because if you but if you
didn't have money in the area but then
it's it's funny because it's like we
want money in areas to help to help yeah
but then it's from no money that usually
really beautifully else can come from
our art comes from like you know
desperation a lot of times so it's so
funny to just have that dichotomy it's
like you need be like when I was young
man Tati given anything to be able to
offer us to have some money for my
mother not to walk her you know to just
to have a little bit of time where we
could have I don't know just felt like
not ashamed of who I was or you know
just I don't know you know what I wish
we'd had some money a little more
comfort yeah but then it's like but you
had to work harder to do what you do
right anything from me like I moved to
Philly to go to university and I had
like nothing it do temples [ __ ] wild
if you go to visit me it's on us [ __ ]
burger market and see so be more it's
somebody trying to crow to drop off
[ __ ] cocaine form of hate yeah yeah
the drug they did they'd run they run
they run drugs on birds up there I just
would park in the middle of [ __ ]
Street and go do it but if you just go
if you just go temple is like a little
bubble of like you know University but
any outside of that area in North
Philadelphia it just looks like
Apocalypse Now like it's burned out
buildings and like it's just it's
[ __ ] street by street just crazy
ghetto from like this will be more all
the way like 40 blocks up kind of
endless like and it's it's I worked up
there well it's a temple I ended up
graduating I didn't even graduate
my fourth year I left cause it's like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] school and I just got a
job as a social worker and I worked up
in these high schools up there and I'm
pretty gangster huh it was [ __ ] up man
I mean like back to the drugs we're
talking about we weren't talking about
job I was talking about
I'm always the kids the kids I was
working with or just so geeked up on
ritalin like they weren't even they
didn't even when the kids could even
read well my kids and they didn't care
it wasn't like let's teach the kid Reid
is like getting rid of and so it doesn't
bother any other kid in school was like
[ __ ] up and these kids are just like
building these the government was
actually building these drug addictions
for these kids from like ten years old
already that's how you put this how you
this just there was no there's no
there's no idea to fix this [ __ ]
place they lived at and like helped with
their parents who were you know dealing
crack on the side there's never like how
do we fix the situation kid lives and so
I just throw him some drugs so we can
move on yeah that was like the way that
the government in the city dealt with it
and I did that for the one I just
[ __ ] quit Wow honestly I learned a
lot from that was my hardest job I've
ever had was doing that doing that it
was called TSS it was like there's two
to staff support I went to schools with
the kids and like helps like wrote notes
about the kids and helped him with
whatever he needed and stuff like that
like one on one with a kid for a few
weeks and it was rough to see like that
that I was like literally shadowing this
kid every day helping him doing reports
somebody was doing you know it's funny I
remember growing up like one of the
hardest things was like just the amount
of poverty that there really isn't a lot
of the black community you know and in
the white community too it's just a
little bit different I feel like but I
mean but this there's so much poverty in
in America still like and it's gonna get
worse and worse for what we have right
now I mean just living in LA you see the
homeless situation how insane that
rolling and to see when you move here
the person I actually take people skid
rotors would be like who were from
Europe like have you ever seen this son
like this because like block by block
and it's like a little community there
and you know a lot people are homeless
in California or like have mental health
problems where they have backs it can't
exists in a normal way and that's like
the last resort for them to survive is
lit be homeless but I've noticed during
this pandemic
there's a lot there's a little I live in
Hollywood there's like one overpass and
it just keeps growing small little
community there
and the people are younger and younger
Wow and they're not even like maybe they
have mental health problems but their
kids are like the well-put-together you
have like some of this girls like punk
rock girl is that everyday she's up in
like seven putting her mohawk in but she
just lives in this tent because she you
know when it was a stay on water she had
nowhere to go
right right live did the parents or
whatever and I had to leave so I think a
lot of kids we're seeing a lot more of
this poverty situation happening with
young people that never happent before
and I think that's not being addressed
in LA it's just it's a [ __ ] a lot of
homeless going on here and I think it's
a lot a lot of money or two which is
shocking you know it's really
interesting I mean even hearing you say
about when you were doing the TSS stuff
and and that water bottle might be
uneven on the bottom of it I saw her
fall yeah just gotta wait you too good I
don't know why we did actually have the
whole in spring sponsorship I think cuz
it was poor I think cuz we were giving
up poor water we're gonna do Dasani for
now I invested in core water yeah in the
beginning I made a lot of money out of
core water I love core water I sold it
dr. pepper and I got dr. pepper stock up
in how do wait a year to sell and I
finally I was like alright no dude dr.
pepper was one of the only beverages
when I was growing up there was like
five beverages and one of them was dr.
pepper
so like it's interesting cuz throughout
time it's like yeah they try to put
different things into communities it's
like like you were saying they try to uh
you know they'll try to diversify
communities like oh let's bus him kids
from different places
let's but let's try and flood it with um
drugs let's use Oh drugs will be the
solution you know I think we're starting
to realize over time that or money let's
trust try and pump money and I think
money definitely helps you know uh you
know a lot of people talk about white
privilege and I think a lot about green
privilege I think there is some white
privilege yeah but I don't know if but I
know that money like you go to you look
at a place like Atlanta I was talking on
busi about it and just when you see that
wealth when you go to Atlanta and you
see for the first time remember the
first one went there it was just it
seemed like just like a the place where
the Braves play right and then over time
it's become you see wealthy black people
and you see oh this is what happens when
a community of people has money they are
they live more I don't want to say
comfortably like in their assets but
comfortably inside of themselves as a
human you know like their you don't see
I mean I think the kid
that I grew up around where it was like
yeah you know kids it just were just you
know some of them didn't have parents
kids like 15 20 years old couldn't even
read you know I mean even even the music
scene I think coming in from Atlanta
recently a lot of these kids you know
buddy grew up hip-hop you know rappers
came from like the lowest parts of a
city or it was like they had to call
their way out to make music and I think
the last 10 years you have kids from the
suburbs yeah actually you're like
changing the game a little now sex
example he's like I think I'm not gonna
speak on his family I think he might be
a middle-class kid but he's like he had
a opportunity to put his energy in
something that maybe he was gonna be
wrapped right right but it was a little
class yeah I've been able to have that
ability and he changed the game he like
the biggest record of all time actually
I think that's something that happened
because of you know putting people in a
position where they can have a little
more opportunities because at some point
I'm a firm believer that anybody in
America can honestly make their way up
to to where they can I know that I'm
gonna have a lot more opportunities
being a white guy right my parents put
me in a place that was made it helped
they're my father you know he was dirt
poor he had no opportunities he had a
good at the Vietnam War just to get it
he was like not even have a job just to
get a GI bill to go to college and go to
college he's like late 20s and he's the
only person to go to college out of like
whole generation his family like hundred
years and he and he made it and like
went to college graduate like in the
like when he's thirty or something and
got a job at a hospital worked his way
up to have a great job at a hospital and
put me to college like gave me the funds
to go to university Central Florida so
he didn't spend that much money but but
I would have never done it I wouldn't I
wouldn't I mean I can get a I can get a
student loan now which I suggest never
doing like to anybody cuz I think it's
the biggest shame there is but I my dad
was able to do that and I think anyhow
so maybe being white you know in down
south also probably helped him secure a
job in different places like Mississippi
or Alabama but at the same time I think
it's possible for anybody but work it's
different like the road is gonna be a
lot flatter from for me to climb then
it's gonna be for a young black guy who
has to go up you know high but if you're
in the middle class that's you know I
think the the economy doesn't really see
race it's like an algorithm just you
zeroes in number it's these numbers
right you know like I think tech phones
all these things like that doesn't
like they're not rate inherently racist
our our political social economic system
in America is inherently racist not it's
probably by default because it's been
built that way and you can't you could
you know you can't deconstruct it that
easily but right it takes time it does
take time but I think yeah you said like
money is gonna give people more
experiences that they can that they can
take I mean having disposable income is
you're gonna spend money on music you're
gonna go to concerts and when we're when
the economy is good exit the music scene
grows a lot more and I mean right now
you're not gonna have a lot of new music
in 2020 because no one's to ring people
are scared put out the records no one's
writing you know spending money at shows
surviving I mean even as you said you
know it's like not a time it's a you
know when people are it hadn't really
been the time really to make maybe new
music yeah you know it's funny yeah I
think you know piggyback on what you're
saying it's like yeah when you're
survive and we have to spend expend
energy surviving you don't it's hard to
fantasize yeah imagine or you dream oh
yeah you know it you can't it's really
hard to do both like me I never had
opportunity I didn't start making music
Todd was like 20 like really pretty
managing to it was like nineteen twenty
most kids like this starting like Billy
ilex I got eleven twelve you know like I
was as even as a DJ and peppers red
girls like 26 and that's like my grandpa
you know a rapper if you're if you're
not coming out at 16 years old now
you're like yeah your grandma yes who
who's your oldest pug so this is Dada
but I think um I think now kids have
that that opportunity like they have a
little like I said like SoundCloud they
don't need that they don't need that
[ __ ] the ceiling they can they can
break through yeah you have a good idea
good concepts but right now there's not
a lot of we're like a tick-tock
generation like musics kind of we're
only digesting 15 seconds of songs right
now yeah it's all you have to have that
hook yeah which is not a lot of tick
tock burgers don't don't make artists
though so if I hope is a phase I don't
I'm not mad at tick tock and I've had
I've used my to talk to my advantage
sometimes but I think a lot of the songs
that come out you get this guy has a
song a tick tock that's like human lucky
examples like might be have like become
a number-one record and still has like
you know 30,000 followers on Instagram
because no one's actually checking for
the artists there right looping this
moment writes about the influencer
that's that's doing it yeah I think tick
tock is just like it's this weird yeah I
don't know if
people become real artists off of there
yeah they don't I think it's a trend
thing but I think hopefully there might
be someone that comes out of it that
you're like oh you know SoundCloud rap
came out I thought it was all kind of
garbage and then X X X X temptation came
out like this guy the real artist came
out of it yeah and like had like like
kind of put the whole thing on his
shoulder even at 16 I never think it
came out I was like he survived it and
lasted so but all those other rappers I
had like songs out there gone you know
it's like they had like one month people
played records it was hype and then wow
do you feel like cuz you you know you do
I mean you know you really love to
experience different cultures it seems
like and and I mean you talk about it's
at the forefront of your communication
you know like do you feel you know a lot
of people get accused of cultural
appropriation and stuff these days which
you know it's it's a huge discussion
topic really but I feel do you but
sometimes it's you're more of a liaison
for cultures i 100% I'm a cultural
appropriator I mean I got Big Ben steel
that I think I just don't think there's
anything wrong with it like even if even
just me doing country music I wasn't
like I know I'm starting to doing
[ __ ] Rodya yeah like I was super
boring like I don't belong so it's not
like yeah but like I think anything you
do culturally like I don't think what
what am I supposed to do like what
defines Mississippi Mike I Florida
muscles like right alligator or you know
just like work Walgreens I don't know
there's not any I don't think anybody
should be defined and if you if you put
rules on culture and music you're
setting yourself up for like
constricting anything any ideas that I
mean like someone just said little no
sex you're not gonna allow to do this
not let him make country music I'm
actually I started doing like more
random music earlier in my career too
way if I started doing like Major Lazer
now what probably would never flown you
know like or if I did like I look back I
like my video in my bounce video for
express yourself this New Orleans I I
couldn't make a video like that now that
girls twerking I'm like only a white guy
in the video and like I'm DJ am I
getting downtown New Orleans I mean like
I look back and like that was a moment
that couldn't happen now because there's
like rules and regulation to that is
there I think yeah malaise I'm as a
producer I'm just that's always been my
job I've been fascinated by music right
the people that
inspired me something like David Bowie
you know he did funk he did you know he
did glam he did like folk music his big
estate was like let's dance in the house
Rogers I mean I was like full-on like
the guy did she come in he just ain't no
one ever said like he's you know
culturally appropriating something he
just was an artist writing art is art
yeah and you have to be influenced like
you have to be influenced about things I
mean my favorite Richard Pryor is my
favorite comedian Chris Rock's my second
favorite comedian and my others is guy
named Jerry clower actually was out of
Yazoo City Mississippi up to sing you
smell his stuff man you've literally
said she was sat here with maybe wonder
[ __ ] once more music I mean I think
with music also we owe a lot like man
like The Clash is might be like my
biggest influence because I start with
punk they did reggae did hip-hop and
they had a record my favorite record of
all time might be watt rock the casbah
was like political was a dance record
it's beautifully done it's produced
really well and if they came out today's
people been like what do you what are
you doing that for you know like what
are you doing but I think that argument
I've been hearing that argument about
culturally appropriate music for like 20
years I just don't go away people listen
my music if they like it they like it I
hope that my music affects you to where
you want to listen to and you're like oh
I love this I love this country even
with the country stuff I mean Nashville
is not [ __ ] with my country music
sometimes I think you listen to they're
like but if a kid like I'm making it for
that fourteen-year-old kid driving
around like I know he doesn't he doesn't
think about like the rules when I since
I'm using sound like listen to that you
know and in fact he probably doesn't
want to listen I think you should I
think you shouldn't but I think he
should have a lot of education on music
because I am as a DJ I've been in I know
so much about music I think that's my
only that's the only thing I've done so
I know where I came from I know that um
I wouldn't be here if it wasn't for
black music even like black and gay
music when it comes to house records I
know where the roots come from and I
know to show support and love when I can
those people because that's actually my
that's what I can do for those people
who are in the scene like if it's like
I'm a young black DJ I'm gonna [ __ ]
book him over another young white DJ
just because or if it's young woman
because that's something I can do right
and that's actually important if I can
make music and get to a position where I
can help other people make more music
well that's the best that I mean it
seems like you tell you that with your
label yeah is it but it does get hard to
juggle though doing your own and then
also being a producer does it hard to
get
not really I think that I used to just
always good the example like Beyonce I
always read mark a record for Beyonce
Rihanna and if they wouldn't take it I
make it my record you know I worked to
make it for them because of the two
artists I was like I was constantly you
know they manage like can we hear some
ideas and I would focus on that and then
I would never get the record done for
them but I would just be like hey I made
this great record that didn't take like
good stories like lean on my biggest
probably record ever made with major
lazer it was written for for Rihanna
originally and the story is I played in
the studio she just was like not a
partner with it and um but blessing
because I owned the Rhett master that
record you know I'm like I made like
shitload of money and the record reached
a lot of people and I was proud of it
and we made a video in India actually
damn we're like stuck with like no money
like say 5,000 and if I met that video
today people would have [ __ ] it would
make canceled you know cause like we're
just like we're just chilling India had
to show their play for all these kids
like let me just spend the money I made
at the show on the video in the in you
know here and we had the girl came out
and in the video it's actually nice and
awesome you know it's a vibe people are
gonna criticize it I mean you're gonna
get Chris is amol time you're gonna get
haters was so long it's art man it's
hard not to and especially these days I
even worried more about comedy it's like
how can I talk about stuff how can I try
and share you know my truth or share
like you know what my story is or even
what my thoughts are
yeah without being sarcastic his loss
that sucks for comedy because yeah
sarcasm is a [ __ ] art form right I
think and people don't [ __ ] get they
don't they don't they don't gonna take a
time to like realize it then you get
stuck on like the quotable or whatever
and then you're you get [ __ ] on
something that you don't you're not even
listen to the context of my joke or
whatever and I think that's comedy
should be indifferent to that but it's
never how it how it gets back to that
because yeah it's like my first my first
Netflix special is a lot of his real
tongue in cheek it's almost like a
character you know in a weird way and
yes some people take it verbatim and
it's like oh you don't see what I'm
doing you can see what's going on here
you know but yes our chasm is really
it's hard you have to be you're gonna
sit goes to your community you have to
give him artistic license I think it was
a fan you should and if something
happens and you in the person in the car
taken out of context dig into it and a
person could defend themselves to I
think it's fair enough but um you should
be careful because you if nothing else I
think cancel culture is pretty
can whack but if nothing else it does
help to take away some of the things
that shouldn't be done right so but I
think we're gonna survive this and
people gonna like what they like this
something's funny and they know it's you
know at the end of day be a good person
be kind know be informed about things I
think well you know when it comes to D
from the police or black lives matter
things like that I'm gonna talk about
politics in the show but I think if you
get into it and you kind of just read a
little bit you can understand a little
bit more about what these ideas what the
curb is the words themselves are really
scary well yeah you think of me neither
yeah if you stay on Twitter you're just
gonna get in fights but I think if you
you know it made me think you know and I
see you as a big proponent of it and you
know being out and involved I saw you
and I don't involved in the protests and
stuff when you're on your Instagram and
it makes it's made me think as a person
and then also as a white person what do
I have differences when I look at a
black person do I have you know do I
have different behavior you know just it
started it's definitely made me think
that and that's and that's the best
thing of it yeah home used to make me
think what you know like am i driving
past impoverished neighborhoods whether
they're black or white or any color it
makes me think like in in thinking oh
man those people don't have anything
right but then thinking well what am i
doing anything in my life to help be a
part of you know the solution like yeah
and even as you said like you were
working as the TSS and you know and then
they tried drugs to help with the kids
and then they try like well let's bus
kids from different areas that'll change
it I think in the end it's human
connection really a hundred percent that
that's good together I think you see
South Africa I was bringing that back up
again these young people like like these
kids are like like a young black I was
talking to and he's like hi his
girlfriend's white and I'm he didn't
ever he's like never thought it was
weird
but of course his parents and her
parents probably were like scared yeah I
think for them and those are kids are
gonna change the world like those kids
that have this new definition of what it
means to be
oh yeah white a young person you bring a
black hero and I pass the red and like
dad will be like you want me to bounce
pass it like you can't make a funny joke
you're like oh my god I mean my dad and
parents like they're still but they're
crying I tried root for them but yeah
like honestly what's happened all this
attention on
non-information is turned a lot of like
my nephews and stuff you were like
actually probably borderline racist
about two years ago are a lot smarter
and they live in a diverse neighborhood
like the high schools probably have like
half white but they headed like psych
jail you know like kind of like go you
have to like [ __ ] find or click and
live with it like you know yeah pure
white person go to jail you get to join
are you guys doing a white supremacist
only way to survive I mean it's like
kind of sucks but it's like that's the
[ __ ] definition we have and I get a
high schooler germ so I think like we
have we had that's gonna be hard to get
past that you know but I think um at the
same time I think my my nephews like I
talked to him a little bit like why do
you write something down on Twitter
because I I was like that's like kind of
concerned about him and then like I kind
of explained to him like not in a
attacking way but I'm like you know
think about things and you know I think
um it helps just like conversate like
literally it's hard because there's so
much misinformation like honestly cuz we
just it's it's an it's not really in our
face when we see the problems that we
just kind of cover them up so right it's
up to everybody you just gotta learn I
mean yeah you gotta learn and it's but
yeah and I think sometimes I even feel
like attacked as a white person's like
well is it you know some people don't
want to talk about you know equality or
talk about some people also or they just
want to be controlling and they you know
so you have to it's hard to like kind of
you know it's just it's tough it's a
tough balance because it's just it's
tribal you know that people feel like
this is my tribe I'm white and I have to
fight for this or whatever they don't
realize like that's in black too
yeah same thing if people think and I
think that's what you know we're in this
position you know and when Trump his
whole campaign is like based on division
he doesn't have a campaign stance you
know I'm not gonna endorse anybody but I
think that it's so easy for him to do
that because that that disinformation
that tribalism is what creates any
energy frame because he has no energy
otherwise he has no stance than anything
is like no peers like no purpose as a
president he's like no I've always seen
as a shady businessman kind of which
sometimes in some aspects of a you know
it's what a lot of America has become
yeah
so I'm not shocked that he's the reason
he doesn't have to he doesn't appear to
have that ability to connect on an
emotional level or under emotionally I
love I love him someone asking like his
favorite Bible chapter he's like I'm not
gonna answer that I love the whole book
Old Testament have some he's like I love
them equally but looks like he has no
idea do you read they didn't read the
Bible's whole life but dude it's almost
you know it's so funny to talk about
resting earlier everything is turned
really into the WWE it's all about 15
second bit it's all about [ __ ] wiU
though goddamn the racial stereotypes
and how crazy it was but it defined me
as I learned about everything like I
love them it was like there was like the
[ __ ] there's like sergeant slaughter
there's the junkyard dog
there was the [ __ ] Australian dudes
there was a [ __ ] Chinese guy that
Iranian terrorists but even some thought
it wasn't a good guy he was a bad guy
was like there's no rules it was like
Hulk Hogan became a bad guy for a while
I was like Huckabee where I came that
bird on his chain it was like the most
they just built the stereotype so crazy
as a kid you like learned about learn
about we were like Tatanka that's how a
lot of us learned about dude the only
Asian you've got be a hero it's a talker
right you probably love your bike yeah
that's my guy I had a hatchet yeah we
come up with a there was no definitions
no good or bad like after a while like
everybody was bad or the good I hit
parts her into a heel if he's there long
enough you become the heel right because
a guy that's like the evil guy totally
they got to spin it around I got one
last question I want to ask you no I'm
just trying to remember what it is in my
head real quick Tatanka
and and I could talk to you forever but
I just you know review dragon steamboat
- oh dude that was the only person that
I knew Yokozuna came in and he was he
was a sumo guy Iron Sheik Iron Sheik hey
remember he got begun Twitter cuz he
yeah he he did the enemy sometime he had
this amazing Iron Sheik and hacksaw jim
duggan story where they were like on a
coke bender together they got arrested
in like alabama or something and they're
supposed to be like arch rivals like
hacksaw jim duggan like the pro mero
yeah Iron Sheik was like the like
Iranian terrorists and they were like
they've partied together and in the
animated the story once they got caught
by the police and
get they had to go to jail together and
they got caught like other friends and
it kind of ruin their whole [ __ ]
story do you see the documentary that
Jake this uh you see the jake the snake'
document now I gotta watch that and it's
so good no is he become governor no Jake
is taking his best thing was though
sometimes he had to check the snake and
they would put it down below in the
plane and the cold air would kill the
snake new snake all the time or
sometimes he'd bring out his bag with a
dead snake in and it just could have
been a emotional support snake nowadays
there's a woman that had a kangaroo on a
plane you had a horse leg reason they
took the horses out those two crazy I
love these and also you can be a [ __ ]
rest and be like 45 and just still be
like a sex symbol yeah I'm either I'm 41
so I need to like figure out my next
move is man and wear those tights man do
you have the uh you know I look at John
Mayer sometimes fit either and no you
just had to be a [ __ ] man they're not
some real gay relatives to come out oh
there was gold dust oh I didn't even
know gold dust was the gateway he was
like borderline gay don't know but you
didn't even even like a controversial
thing racism I was like no there's no
rules man don't you find how interesting
it is dusty rose son mm-hmm don't you
find it interesting how online people
are one way in in real life they're
different they're different yeah I mean
I'll also be on lines anonymous you
don't have to be anything you just be
fake people are inherently like racist
is because they want to do that I mean
talk that's what the kind of the online
world kind of sucks yeah cuz you don't
really get a real person out there
anymore you know yeah it's funny cuz you
would argue with someone but if you met
with them and disent I had the same
conversation you would not it probably
wouldn't be an argument also people like
you know they wanna they want to stroke
controversy and they like just they'll
do it for weeks and just to get a little
hype on things like some guys some other
DJ's right like called me out during
this whole process moment and I'm like I
know the people and I'm like bro you're
gonna get a couple retweets for this and
I'm TM like you know are you gonna dyke
this fourth like not have your
friendship with me anymore for this and
some numbers like you know how to cut
people off sometimes like this
like yeah the gates just to get a little
height be a little retweet is like talk
to me doing a problem you know like
let's do something let's hash it out
yeah yeah yeah let's discuss it and
here's here's post Malone son Gang Gang
wassup Co what's up Diplo I got a
question for Diplo if you weren't making
electronic music what do you think you'd
be doing like if that just wasn't an
option what do you think you'd be doing
right now
much love guys take care it's funny cuz
I was gonna ask you know Johnny I've
seen him do comedy before yeah
and he's I thought he was extremely
funny for a guy who doesn't get to get
reps like everyone else because and the
reason he says he doesn't is because I
can't get up there at a blank slate
anymore
it's just they won't it's not how it's
gonna interact with society you know you
people get to get up and practice the
blank slate yeah so and I think he would
have been a great comedian is there is
there something else you like but he
doesn't have enough time it's funny with
life you only get really so much time I
mean he he I saw him once do at the
peppermint lounge with Dave Chapelle as
well as long as we lock your phone up
and I think it was a lot of the stuff
that was on Dave's like we didn't f they
didn't f look special or something like
tears ago yeah yeah so he did a lot of
that a lot of that material and it was
pretty controversial and I think he kept
some about something I get me repeat
something but he had like Eddie Murphy
there I was like all it was a go and it
was awesome because it was like that was
like a no [ __ ] holes bar like do
whatever he wanted without the phones
cuz you can't really yeah word of mouth
he did some controversial no one cares
write a video of it yeah it's like it's
it's evidence or whatever right clubs
have started doing that lock in your
phone yeah which is kind of I guess it's
kind of the only way to keep keep people
like that's it's your experiences here
you're not gonna take this and go get a
gotcha moment or not comedian or
something yeah but he did with John
Mayer was awesome to be like the mean it
was very improvised Mitchell I think the
whole thing was improvising that that's
scary to me but they have reports like a
podcast I guess right you just kind of I
mean we wouldn't be very good maybe you
are the person practice a little bit but
uh they had it they had like they had a
chemistry it just works
I think job but I just thought I feel
like John is just a genius and in almost
could have gotten into a couple
different things you know but he got
into music and so that's where his
creativity his his current mood is
awesome though his little TV show you oh
yeah it's great
Instagram live and he's the first guy to
do before all these before there was
like pornos on Instagram live which took
over he was like had the first poppin
Instagram live and it was really funny
and very clever and he's [ __ ] smart
guy he's really smart guy do you but do
you see but is there something else do
you feel like man if I had a head more
but do you think you could have been you
know you're a great producer do you
think you know an entertainer I'm always
been something else I'm always I'm like
a cultural agitator you know you might
say like cult-like you know whatever it
is I think that you can go in and read a
lot about what cultural appropriation
means but I was always felt like a
cultural agitator to where I'd like I
went to school the reason I went to
temples cuz I went to school for
anthropology because I was obsessed with
culture like literally I was obsessed
with like what it means to be human
being like what what it isn't to be
creative and what do you what is it what
defines you from who you are to create
what you are and I was obsessed with
like the history of people in like
different places like why do Japanese
people dress like this and where they
make music like this and what's Hindu
religion about and like what does it
mean to be like you know maybe if what's
it like to be living in Texas and like
work out of cement factory like what is
this like this is what I was always
obsessed with and I went to school for
anthropology and documentary filmmaking
and I was like I really wanted to bring
people and culture to life in an in a
clinic clever way in a new way and I've
worked on some documentaries even made
one a couple years ago before I started
making music about Brazil because I was
like obsessed with like the music there
and the culture and the weirdness of it
it's just [ __ ] weird like yes
Salvador wanted it was wild no cuz that
place is just defined by it's a [ __ ]
mess there's no it's like it's European
it's Portuguese African it's Japanese
it's like all those things create
something and that's what that's why
I've kind of like always shy away from
like discussing like what it means to
create culture cuz new cultures
mutations and it hurts a movement for
things to be created you have to put two
things together that this shouldn't
belong or better random like you know a
Japanese like the go-to in Sawle Paulo
there's a neighborhood called Liberace
and it's 1 million Japanese Brazilians
live in this neighborhood and you walk
around see like Japanese guy his name
like you know Miguel Carvalho kawasaki
and you've got like long hair and he's
[ __ ] walk around like a [ __ ] G and
you're like that's not a bad
but that's like that's a real [ __ ]
right that's a thing that's like I'm
like I love that that is this and like
what what's like what's comes from that
and I go what why is there Samba music
or bossa nova and it comes from these
things that just explosions right and
that's what culture is to me and I
always want to be part of that I love
that so you love culture man so even
it's not just the music music just seems
to be the easiest way for people to 2x
to digest cultures like music because
that's like gonna be your introduction
to country music your inductors are like
African music this the music is it
you're not to read about the history of
Africa to like understand a Nigerian
record it just affects you right that's
why I love music and the idea of culture
but um I would love to work back in film
and documentary yeah that would be cool
if I get older because I mean you know
my days are numbered as a DJ I hope that
I want to be like a 55 year old DJ if I
if I can make it that long I'll do it if
it pays the bills but I'm being at the
end of day I want to I want to age
gracefully and do more do more things I
think music was one thing I do maybe
it's film and TV next I don't know yeah
hey I want a piece of shop or something
yeah maybe a woodworker I could see that
dude would you um I have to [ __ ] pee
so bad man I have to pee too yeah if you
wanna watch the movie it's it's an hour
it's hour and 25 minutes but it's not
that well done by funded the whole movie
by myself like I would get shows out
really Brazil have a long blast yeah I
would get money from shows and go back
to Brazil and bring a camera and like
shoot you know I've got it with you it's
a guy in Brasilia a new name Leandro is
a filmmakers I met I worked at this
magazine called colours as a young
provide a job there and I met a bunch of
filmmakers and stuff and I just kept in
touch them before internet you know and
it's like 2007 or something no it says
it was before and I just met some
creative people and I met this guy we
made a movie together and I would never
ever suggest doing something like this
on your own like I just like the biggest
waste of money I made like and having
like the pressure of creating it and
like heaven like be stingy on the budget
like everything I made money-wise I put
like a million for that couple years so
and yeah you go halfway down the road
you got to get all the way there yeah
yeah yeah me too if we go pee together
there's a difference also azekah oh this
one I want to ask you about so ego so
like you know in the last couple years
I've had a bigger career right and so
you know there are moments where my ego
starts to get big you know and I and I
never always you knew I had maybe some
ego we all have it yeah but I never
really thought like oh well what is you
know like and there's moments where it
started to feel really continued not out
of control but it grows without my
consciousness of it growing do you ever
have any issues like with that or just
be ever able to see that in your own
like I think I think I think that's
people probably see it more than I do
you know when it comes to ego because
I'm just like I'm not I'm my kind of an
independent person and maybe it affects
other people's lives like they'll let my
friends are my family you know sometimes
they put me in check but for the most
part I mean being humble was where I
think I got where I'm at like you always
gotta pay dues and just feel feel good
but if you really want to e go check
it's go on Twitter every once awhile
just see what people are talking about
[ __ ] about no break you down pretty
quick I also think I started about four
years ago I did ayahuasca for the first
time and that's a [ __ ] ego deflator
like hardcore yeah I do that and it's
like a drug that kind of puts you like
he might even poop your pants it just
kind of breaks down yeah that whatever
you feel it you become like a Mormon it
naturalizes you in a way ain't it yeah I
can give you the shame like you're
puking and you're thinking of things and
you don't you just it's it's you're it's
dark and then just bright and you just
you go through a lot of things the best
way to explain it how it helps you is
that you have a messy closet right I
mean when you do ayahuasca it kind of
helps put everything in the drawers so
it you can like understand things a
little better because that's what your
brain probably is like a messy closet
sometimes but I've done that not the two
times I did it it really helped ground
me to where I had another outlook a
little bit and I try to use that message
now when I you know because it is
important to not have it you go but a
same time he goes back to six nine I got
him where he's at like even if he even
if it's a whole big play he knows he's
using it towards advantage sometimes it
could work it kept good backfire
yeah if you don't have it planned out if
you're not playing chess with it if
you're playing like checkers with it you
could backfire on you but
yeah we had on you know one of my
favorite comedians has got Chris D'Elia
and he would always reference you on his
Instagram called yeah did you ever
interact with them about that did you
think it was yeah well he was friends
with Dillon Francis early on and I I
think I met him through that and we I
never met him actually but we just
didn't understand enough he was make a
funny or not the beginning but I was
tweeting it I thought it was pretty
funny yeah it's so funny but I was like
I'm not even that special but I guess
I'm like a b-level celebrity picked up I
thought you could put could pick
somebody better or whatever but it it
was kind of cool I got a lot of like a
lot of people always tagged me when he
did that yeah because then I got to be I
got to go to once I started getting like
nice green room and some of like what am
i Chris D'Elia it made it so it was fun
from paper cuz then I got to do it to
just make fun like make bring him into
it you know be part of his thing from it
but yeah I was just wondering how that
landed on you never I never really bad
we he always come at my Instagram and he
was like dude fucking's he's bizarre
like you know it's really cool about him
it was like real creative you scratch
your head when used to some of the stuff
he does I think Dillon Francis another
DJ was like kind of like borderline
comedy and a DJ which is kind of a cool
space cuz no one really does that but
Dylan was really acts and his in TV
shows and stuff like that but yeah it's
to to creative man he's like he's like
riff raff sometimes you watch those
videos like what the [ __ ] in the he's
time I even land him to be funny it's
just almost like just it's just
something which is great was a real
creator can kind of not really aim for
like a success but just like a shock
value thing another guy who I love who's
kind of like half comedian half dancer
is this guy named um [ __ ] to have to
look him up
I always forget his name he's a dancing
guy he is gonna take a second to edit
this out no worries just got cholo fake
creeper that I'll like who's Latino I
was a dark face guy to that he's like
he's like a [ __ ] kind of like dancing
yeah yeah yeah I was sending this thing
to uh
Frankie Frankie King Jonas which i think
is the best I say if I could have any
last name it would be kinking moon is
this good one yeah it's uh this guy
Casey Frei oh yeah Casey price bro I
mean he first of all he's one of the
sickest dancers ever and he doesn't
really dance that often but his like
some of his comedy is just like so what
the [ __ ] and then the way he integrates
like dance and comedy like I don't think
think he does he doesn't on purpose he
just is like just especially - yeah yeah
yeah I play bass holder come we know
each other just from he's a friend's a
lot of DJ's and I just love that guy
he's like so he inspires me a lot
he seems really cool people always say
you gotta talk to Casey Freyr you got to
connect to them maybe that's a good vibe
that I need to I think that's everything
that I had man I mean I could keep
talking about stuff but you know I just
wanna yeah thank you for your time and
it's interesting yeah man I do think
it's interesting how like even if I'm
talking you know it makes me want to
know a little bit more about you know
makes women know more about music but it
makes me want to also have a little bit
more respect for like the history of
music because yeah people don't realize
like that even just like humans like
music comes from like parents yeah you
know like music like each sound has like
a couple of parents you know and
grandparents and then I mean I think you
do the same thing with that I do with
comedy like you know the history like
you said some of your favorite comedian
oh yeah I think I think it like that you
know what you're you're gonna be you
know you're you're the comedy of right
now so you have to take all the things
that happen before you understand that
twist it up and then know how far you
can push things and I heard Kevin Hart
say at once like he has a black comedian
he always like he's gonna push it
further than he'd been and then there's
gonna be someone at five years gonna
push it further than him it's like their
job
his ideas just blaze a trail I think you
it's gonna be the same thing like you
know the history you're gonna push it as
the character that you are and the
person you are and I think it's a little
bit difficult now cuz you have to walk a
tighter line with almost like the
challenge part of me said last week I
was like you know two weeks ago I was
scared yeah and then last week I was
like you know what this is what it is
you know and I think that I can do it
it's gonna make people be a little bit
tighter about what they do almost when
you have a set of rules and it sounds
[ __ ] up cuz we're just talking about
how there should be no rules or anything
but it also can create something special
I'm gonna be really boring metaphor you
probably edit this out but I was a film
school and I went to a class a class
called Iranian Iranian cinema but um
Iran has this amazing film industry in
the 90s and there's a director called
Abbas Kiarostami and he made a record
movie called like water water for some
about chocolate water for chocolate
something like something for Chow maybe
look at the film cuz I don't wanna
[ __ ] butcher water from chocolate but
he is a famous director because in Iran
it's such a Muslim country in the rules
to make a film I can't show any women
without the hair mask you have to talk
about God in certain ways there's like
all these [ __ ] rules these guys made
these films where it's like such an
arrow a lion like a walk and they always
win like war it's worldwide for these
films they make this guy especially
because it's just like he made a lot of
films but I think he having those rules
and having no I have to work inside that
came something really hit the push even
harder to get that creative juice in
people to know you're talking about him
make a message happen so yeah cuz the
rules it was almost like when the
teacher or if the government whatever it
is it tells you okay this these are the
rules it's there's something then inside
of you that's like okay okay I see your
rules yeah I'm gonna play by the rules
but watch what I'm yeah yeah final
loophole or something yeah man that's
fair it's pretty fascinating
Thomas Leslie thank you so much for
being here do you like Diplo do you like
tells you my real name is actually
Thomas Wesley pence but just like I put
the Thomas West in my first middle name
because a lot of country guys have two
first names kind of but yeah the West is
my real name people call me Wesley do
you feel like uh do you feel like you
are still Diplo do you feel like it's
been like like you're a snake or
something ever that said it's and do you
feel like it's just something that I
mean people people when they swim with
fans see me now they go Thomas they just
read my Wikipedia page whatever they
don't want they don't wanna say Diplo
it's also not very cool name but it's
like you know it's it's more tried
almost rival yeah there's no weird way I
kind of it isn't it never had really got
define reason to be called that but I
you know whatever it worked it worked
for me and I did a lot of different
music but at this point I have so many
different little bags like I dude like
Thomas Wesley who did like
I did this thing called Silk City with
Mark Ronson did think all LSD with a SIA
and labyrinth and it was like
psychedelic project so I'm just like
fascinated with like you can do things
you can many different things and you
can be different people and that's kind
of like though it throws you into a
tussle if you kind of want to bring out
the cultural whatever I could do
whatever so you can't really enough I
know
no group can be mad at me for too long
so I'm gonna next thing but something
figure out what they're mad about it's
interesting the cultures that are kind
of within us even within hours here
within our types of thought you know
like sometimes were not even recognized
that repeated thoughts that we have
inside of us or even take on a culture
of our own and if we're afraid to act on
those or we like kind of putting a damn
on like some ability of our own
creativity and stuff art is like man
that's the one theme and a boxes like
he's just you're keeping yourself from
so many experiences that could happen
you know yeah it's always about being
like opening yourself up a little bit
and you know it's all about just being a
nice good person being kind having
empathy and create but Korea you know do
things responsibly it's not that hard
you can [ __ ] up
also you can [ __ ] up and [ __ ] fix it
and say ah [ __ ] yeah you can say you can
[ __ ] up I mean look at people always
talk about on xxx sensation I brought
them up a lot in this conversation I
know if you knows music that well but he
had a terrible as a rapper that um ya
know if just if his death and he had a
terrible history with women and violence
and women and um a lot of people you
know brought him off for that and and I
feel like they if they want to they
can't have the rights do that but he
affects a lot of people's lives where
they just let his music really touch
people in a way that rap hasn't done
that a long time and people like have
records that had this like Kurt Cobain
feeling which is really in raw and that
people effected that way like go peep to
the same thing
and I think it's okay for him to work at
himself and be better and I think the
music like I said musics about feeling
the music is something that doesn't have
to have history sometimes right a lot
people die me and you can also define
like Michael Jackson take him off the
radio some people say like that I mean
do what you want I'm not gonna take
Michael Jackson off my myotubes I'm not
gonna stop playing his records if you
don't give people the ability to like
recognize or learn yeah or evolve or
anything some people show me such a king
everybody should be defined by their
history look a good example like Malcolm
X you know if he had wrote him off like
you know beating women and going to
prison and doing things and with the
prison changes life and became a great
leader and an amazing you know
philosopher in a way so the people have
a lot to offer yeah I think you need to
define like what is it that's not right
and let them know that and like let them
change and hopefully that makes it
better for other people yeah cuz cancel
culture it's easy to take down
celebrities but you're not taking down
the guy next to you at a bus whatever
that's actually doing damage or like
verbally abusing or a woman that's you
know right so we have to we have to find
the way so it changed those things like
where it words words normalized for
people in everyday culture like in a
frat or whatever it is that's gonna be
the ones to change the world not the not
just like yeah somebody you got your
moment on a it's on a Twitter or
something but yeah yeah I agree man it's
it's definitely disheartening to see
like some of the some of that culture
you know uh but yeah but it's but to
take it into our regular lives you know
you need to recognize okay well first of
all what are my own behaviors that I
could be you know like even going back
to the black lives matter movement and
and just seeing a lot of that going on
you know like it just made me think like
okay well what let me I'm really ask
myself you know if I if I'm talking to a
black person do I have different
acting's in the back of my head yeah
while I'm talking with them you know or
if I'm if I'm with one of my black
friends a Mamba hate you know like just
little things which some of it's okay
some of it's just nature and it's gonna
be but just make sure just to check
myself to see what's going on you know
and and we have to we have to allow
spaces where people can do that I mean
in P their life's about learning and
changing I mean if we want to say it so
no one can change [ __ ] we're not we're
[ __ ] who [ __ ] cuz that's we got to
change anybody's that change and and
that's okay
okay to do better yeah yeah it's okay to
do better
Thomas Wesley thanks so much for being
here man yeah but next country
[Music]
little time for me to set that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]